welcome to film courage this is episode
156 and I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brannon today's guests are brothers
Franz and Kurt wisner in 1999 Franz
Wisner thought he had his whole life
mapped out a careful planner and skilful
to-do list maker he had the car the
house the promising career path and
eventually the right woman with whom to
experience his success as he had just
proposed to his girlfriend the wedding
ceremony was set for a california
coastal resort in Sonoma County 100-plus
guests were confirmed catering was in
place until his fiancee backs out about
a week before the event understandably
Franz is devastated and listening the
help of his seattle-based younger
brother Kurt a recent divorcee he urges
Franz to stay with the wedding plans
instead turning it into a party amongst
family and friends within the same week
as his relationship breakup Franz is
lobbying position at the irvine company
in Orange County California a job he
knew would be the vessel to channel his
pain of newfound bachelorhood through is
severely altered Franz receives a
demotion at work further crushing his
carefully planned life Franz and Kurt
decide to take the Costa Rican honeymoon
previously planned for Franz and his
fiancee although the brothers weren't as
close as they would have liked and both
were in life situations which made them
question fulfillment they decide to sell
their homes and other possessions
continuing this honeymoon by traveling
to fifty plus countries for two years
while on the road the brothers interview
strangers abroad on the meaning of love
and life the result of this experience
gave way to the New York Times
bestseller honeymoon with my brother
written by Franz and shared through
experiences with Kurtz and 2010 Franz
released another book outlining lessons
from his journey entitled how the world
makes love and what it taught a jilted
groom Franz and his photographer brother
Kurt have appeared on oprah' The Today
Show CNN Fox News and more lots now
welcome to the film courage studio
bonds and Kurt Wisner hello Joan hello
yes hello hello for being here that
sounds pretty good thank you we get most
of them right yeah yeah I know I know by
it sound like a good movie we're good
we're gonna talk a little bit about that
you can follow these guys on Twitter at
Franz wisner and that Kurt was there
although Kurt said he's not but now he's
not big on tweeting and if you're
compelled by their story as much as we
are don't be afraid to send them some
love we also encourage you to learn more
about them by visiting honeymoon with my
brother calm and how the world makes
love calm well again welcome gentlemen
and thanks so much for being here what a
fantastic story and I know it happened
about what ten years ago there were okay
right at 10 years ago okay and
definitely not how I thought my
honeymoon would go you're one hundred
percent correct that I was a big planner
I made these lists every day and then
literally within the span of a week I
get left at the altar and dumped at my
job as well and so is this double whammy
that really hit me although i should say
it was a triple whammy because after
going into my boss's office at the
company and how we explained that hey
you know we've done some reorganizing
here you know used to be at the top of
the pyramid night at the bottom of the
pyramid I'm thinking uh-oh bad luck
comes in threes right it always does so
I go back to my office and there's a
woman in there and she's measuring my
couch and I had this beautiful black
leather couch office overlooking the
Pacific Ocean in Newport Beach and I
said what are you doing she says oh it's
not going to fit in your new office and
I thought ah there's my third right so
in the span of a week not only did I get
dumped at the altar and dumped at my
work I also lost a really beautiful
black leather couch Wow and I a
wonderful few I guess damn a wonderful
view so it was after that that I was as
driving home and Kurt my brother was
staying with me for a little bit just to
make sure I didn't go off the deep end
and I had this idea on the drive home I
I came came in the door and I said hey
Kurt you know
I'd like to go on a honeymoon and he
said with whom and I'm like no no no you
don't understand I said I've got you
know two weeks in Costa Rica I've got
the you know honeymoon suites I got
champagne I've got flowers and he's like
well honeymoon suites have one bed and
oftentimes its heart shape and i love
you i want to help ya but there ain't no
I'm and spent two weeks in Costa Rica
and a heart-shaped bed with you so I
said no no don't worry about it and
we'll all sleep on the floor and we took
off and what was going to be two weeks
in Costa Rica and the other that we got
some funny looks down there because we
booked this big honeymoon package and
you know they they take honeymoons very
seriously in Costa Rica a big deal am so
we go to these resorts and the guy would
be standing out front needs hey mr. and
mr. was where's mrs. wizna I don't we
tell now she got cold feet okay and so
but it was it was good for us and that
you know we had drifted apart we weren't
very close he lived in Seattle I lived
in Southern California and we just
didn't see each other a lot we didn't
speak to each other by phone a lot and
we just like so many brothers and
sisters you know you kind of go to
college you start a family somewhere
else you just drift apart and that
certainly was us and so it was during
this two weeks we had you know such a
good time having those conversations
that brothers should have and clearing
our heads and reevaluating life that
that's when we decided to extend the two
weeks into two years in 53 countries
what a backtrack just for a sec though
you grew up in Davis California and that
right okay in da morning what was what
was that like I mean I think I've driven
through davis it's near Sacramento and
nice town it's a lovely town and it's a
great place to grow up it's the it's the
kind of place where as a child you can
get on your bike and your parents let
you go away for the whole day as long as
you're home by dinner so it's not as
today's society where it's so hands-on
watching your kids and everything so
protective Davis was a very
you know it was a it was a it was a
wonderful place to grow up okay so you
could trust your neighbors and things
like oh definitely i'm another element
to this about growing up in Davis's that
are our parents took us on sabbaticals
and our father is a retired physician in
his group had a little sabbatical
program so growing up we lived in New
Zealand for a while we lived in
Australia for a while and as kids I were
such huge proponent of taking your kids
on the road getting them out there
because I you know for us at a very
early age we realized hey you know the
world is much more similar than
dissimilar that you can have fun
anywhere and make friends anywhere and
and the road is is wonderful and
something to be embraced not this
frightening thing to avoid so those
seeds were planted many many years prior
okay and you both went to college where
I attended University of Oregon in
Eugene Oregon go ducks ya go doc solo
and I'm a tufts jumbo alumni yeah Tufts
well I think you mentioned too that your
parents were very supportive of you but
they also had expectations they wanted
you on the right career path what was
your initial goal either in college or
out of college well I was I worked very
heavily in government and politics and
in public relations but you know it was
starting to get burned out on that I
mean it's a very all-consuming
profession I equate it to the it's kind
of the opposite of travel and that
politics is all about dividing right
drawing lines you're with us you're
against us your pro this your anti this
whereas travel is is about a racing
lines you know you go to a country and
you meet someone and the first thing you
do is you talk about what you have in
common not what you have apart and so
you know that that definitely phrase on
you and it's a much much better
emotional state when I'm embracing and
traveling
I was in government and Kurt what about
for you what were your plans for after
college did you envision anything like
this did you have a set goal well I'm a
typical second-born so Franz is the
firstborn planner Taipei has his whole
career set me I didn't know had no plans
okay I kind of position then yeah
whatever you have this is it 1999 you
have the wedding plan something had
their wedding plan right so on 4g Ranch
California beautiful place right on the
Sonoma Coast like you mentioned um but
it's also one of these places that it's
it's remote and that's what keeps it
beautiful but you need to you know ship
the flowers and from somewhere in the
food in and the wine and and so you need
to make plans well in advance if you're
going to have a wedding up there so so
when it when Annie dumped him you know
just days before the wedding we started
making these phone calls I told France
hey we got to start trying to recoup
some of this money and tell all these
people they don't need to go and the
responses we received from the people we
called work you know what I got the kids
out of school we've got the house rented
up there we're actually going anyway so
it was just a matter of me convincing
Franz that he should be there as well
and he was that he wasn't bored at first
but he finally came around and it turned
out to be a very I think it was a weird
weekend for you but I was surreal range
it was surreal and of 150 people that
were invited 75 showed up so my side of
the aisle exactly and we drank every
ounce of the wine ate every ounce of the
food and yeah every emotion possible i
think was going through my head you know
I was confused I was heartbroken I was
angry I was suspicious a little bit
relieved on some levels also drunk and
broke right so the party is over I'm
sure you you know you probably had
people consoling you and saying you know
you're gonna find love again what
happens once everybody leaves I mean
where does the initial sort of chaos of
the weekend wear off and then you go
okay this is my life where am I going
I think with any setback and trauma
that's that's usually the case friends
rally around immediately but then you
know you get into your routines and the
phone calls you know drop off a little
bit in the visits drop off and in but
you're stuck with this pain and so I it
did it it I cycled through a lot of
emotions and then got two more of a sad
place a depressed place and that's why
when we decided to go on this honeymoon
and then to extend this honeymoon man
that's a great way to keep your mind off
of you know anything that's that's wrong
in your life and to start focusing on on
others and learning about the world and
stop you know feeling so sorry for
yourself and you know some people go to
a counselor for help you know our we
went to the world you know some people
need a world to help that's not that's
us we need a world help and Kurt you had
been through some painful things earlier
in your life and without going into them
too much how are you able to be there
for your brother I I know you mentioned
too that you weren't as close as you
would have liked growing up but how are
you able to kind of be there for him
emotionally physically well here's this
brother who I you know I've idolized all
throughout all of his achievements in
college and in his career my mom would
send me articles about all these great
things that he's done and so Ted to see
his life come crumbling down around him
I just I you know just that the
brotherly instinct came out and me and
it just I had to be there for him and
and you know that it was it was it made
a whole lot of sense for us to extend
that initial trip to Costa Rica because
you know like you mentioned the some of
the stuff I was going through my life
just gotten out of divorce and not super
happy with my job up in Seattle so it
made perfect sense for us to extend this
traveling you know I wouldn't trade it
for the world you know when the bottom
was taken off from underneath you Franz
you know how long did it take you to
regain your confidence because obviously
you're distracting yourself you're
you're in Costa Rica
and then you're going through this but I
have to imagine it took quite a while
before you felt like you know what I'm
finally me again it did and we started
dating on the road not not each other I
started she has another video I know I
started dating you know women in
different countries and Kurt you know as
well every envy of every man and it but
the at first and I write about this in
the book a lot and and they're they're
kind of awkward and they're fumbles and
there there's nothing romantic about
these situations on the road and until
you know we got to Brazil and then I met
somebody who I thought was pretty cool
and she was wonderful and and I thought
I was gonna lose my honeymoon part but
and and it was never one of these things
it was going to be a long-term marriage
but it was it was a neat friendship that
developed and she was very helpful
Brazil as a country is a wonderful
country for a number of reasons is it's
a great I think anybody who gets
divorced or goes through a breakup
should book that first plane down to
Brazil there you go enjoy some of that
Jawad Aviv it's just such a warm and
open place I mean even you land in the
airport and the first thing you hear
they you know most airports have a very
you know official sounding voice you
know now boarding flight number 12 in
Brazil it's this you know very famous
woman Hooper's and so she says you know
now boarding vaadi flag number 124 it's
a powder and it puts you in the lead
right away right away so i also want to
talk about your leap of faith you know
because when you're selling your house
you're selling your stocks and pretty
much all you own you know did you really
know what you were doing at that time
and not only that but you know you go
and you convince her to do the same
thing I mrs. Rooney
that you know no is the short answer the
the star of the book and the star of our
lives during that time was a woman named
LaRue and LaRue was our ninety eight
year old grandmother step grandmother
who had married our grandfather when she
was 80 so she didn't come into our lives
until much later but she lived in a
retirement home and we went into her you
know when we were thinking about doing
this and we said hey LaRue guess what
you know we're going to quit the jobs
and give everything away and go on keep
on the honeymoon and she said great she
said do it you know she said I tell you
what I'll go with you and we we set up
okay you know the honeymoons not really
going according to plan anyhow but you
know welcome you know come unless she
said no no no no she says I'm gonna do
this I'm going to buy a map of the world
and i'm going to buy a bunch of red pins
and then you guys send me a postcard a
letter wherever you go and then i'll put
the pins in the map you know we'll we'll
follow along i'll share the post cards
with the whole retirement home will go
with you and it was so interesting
because to a person they embraced the
trip they embrace the notion of extended
travel they embrace the notion of doing
it when you're young so many of them
said I wish I could do that now you know
my brother has already passed away um I
don't have the body to do it I got the
time i get the money um I wish I spent
more time with my family I wish I
traveled more when I could do it you
know and that you know really gave us a
lot of inspiration you know hey here
these people you know a high on this
mountain of life and with a really clear
view of what's important and what isn't
important and not one of them said you
know don't do it and so we trusted in
LaRue and her retirement home and kept
the promise in a week everywhere we went
we'd send him postcards I still have
this big box of postcards
and then we ended the honeymoon at the
ruse 100th birthday and came back and
had a little celebration right and it's
really great we like we liked her advice
better than our parents because they
were you know concerned about the the
nitty-gritty stuff of you know what are
you gonna do about insurance and your
job and all those kind of things we do
LaRue and her generation you know could
see the light at the end of the tunnel
there you know vice and crime how easy
was this for you and he said you hadn't
been much of a planner you know you
looked up to you old your brother you
know the brothers like this is what I
want to do and I mean how easy of a
decision was this for you to say you
know what I'm all-in I'm gonna do this
with you I like I referenced before the
timing was perfect because here i was
recently divorced not enjoying my job up
in seattle so it was just the little
nudge i needed as well to go out and see
the world and to get to know a brother
who I had lost contact and you weren't
terrified as you're selling your house
and you just like sure uh you know I
think it any any of those big
life-changing decisions and you know
we're gonna make you pause for a second
thought but no looking back it was
definitely the right thing to do there's
this great scene and when you talk about
getting rid of everything we had a
garage sale and basically just to give
stuff away you know and Kurt put the ad
out in the newspaper but he didn't he
didn't say no early birds which we
learned if you don't clearly specify no
early birds no early bird they knock on
your door at like porn 1 okay I remember
this guy comes and knocks on the door
you know silverware do and or there was
that lady in though as I'm walking back
to my room there was a lady in the
window and she kind of knocks and she's
like antiques antiques ahead so we had
this crazy scene where you know we're
just basically giving stuff away you
know you want a chair all right you know
25 cents yeah Kurt sold his old wedding
photo
you know the the enormous kind you know
the big is a fireplace uh he sold it to
a woman for a dollar and the only reason
why she bought it is because her son was
getting married and she just wanted the
frame for her son's when but oh so she
buys it and then she starts ripping the
photo out of the frame and Kurt's like
no no no no no you got to take the whole
thing you know I'm giving it to you for
a buck you know come on so yeah we and
then that was very liberated yeah that
are liberal the all the the you know
people you know gardeners and you know
like the mailman and anybody who was in
the neighborhood kind of sees this free
for all so they start backing up trucks
and we're just like loading in you know
all the stuff that doesn't matter at all
yeah that was a neat feeling at the end
of that day my whole life had been about
accumulation and you know you get one
car and then you want immediately want
the next car and you you know buy a
house let me think about a bigger house
and it's never satisfied that net that
never ends you know people who make ten
you know million dollars want to make 20
million dollars and generate but when
you start going the other way it's as
addictive as materialism you you know I
remember we did a run to salvation army
we packed up all these boxes and I
remember dropping it off and thinking
immediately uh what next you know what
else could we can we give away until we
went you know back and did another load
and and you get addicted in that and
that's that feels great because at the
end of that process that you feel so
strong you know you feel so alive that
you have zero material possessions that
hold you down that way you down um you
know all but no car payment don't no
mortgage no no cell phone no pager no
bills no nothing is you feel human could
you literally feel the weight come on
yes yes yeah Wow I want to go back to a
2005 article in the LA Times and i
believe the writer quotes an
acquaintance of yours saying that their
journey became the subject of awe and
envy I'd love to do the same but only if
i'm day dreaming a lot of people i
suspect lived vicariously through franz
saying secretly to themselves i wish i
had the stones to do something like that
cleaning it out her if I weren't married
I mean I chuck it all down to the car
house job everything and be able to do
that but very few people are willing to
hit the eject button now as things have
changed drastically in the economy
people's homes of lost value their
stocks of lost value are people coming
up to now even more so saying I wish I
had done this well i would put myself in
that category too I mean I I definitely
wouldn't I was not the guy to do it you
know I had I just been dumped at the
altar I would have poured all my
energies into my job and had I just been
you know dumped at my job I would have
poured all my energies into my
relationship but it was really this
double-whammy that forced me to go out
on the road and I mean it was it was so
it was such a strong blow these two
pillars the two pillars of my life
crashing that that only then did I start
thinking wait a minute you know maybe
there's this isn't the path and I'm
supposed to be on and maybe there's
another path for man and literally the
road just opened up at that point and I
you know still having these tickets to
go on the honeymoon and only you know I
I wish I was you know brave enough to do
it but the truth is I was and I was
pushed in it and you know I I would have
gotten married I would have I wasn't the
one who said you know what this doesn't
feel right you get a lot of the sympathy
when you're the dumpee but a lot of
times the dumper is the one
who you know has has more of the stones
as you said and and you know god bless
her for dumping me it was the best thing
that ever happened in my life mmm what
would you say to people for the two of
you that are facing similar things in
their lives I mean so many people have
just had their lives uprooted what would
you talk to them about in terms of
letting go because I think we all have
this vision of what our lives are
supposed to look like especially by a
certain age I think it's difficult I
think you know Franz made reference to
it earlier about the power of travel is
therapy and we get a lot of really
lovely emails from folks for a variety
of reasons but a lot of them hit along
the hit on the lines of that the art
book and our story has inspired them to
take a trip whether they've gone through
a tough breakup or something some
tragedy in their life and and have used
our sort stories as you know evidence
that you can do it and we have these one
these two guys trip sorry from Tulsa
Oklahoma City of these the emails we
sold the truck you simply we cancelled
the lease on our apartment we're going
to Costa Rica we're gonna follow his
conflicts up and they'd like we check
back with him a month later they didn't
do it but I was but I was hard up for
you yeah you know I was thinking about
your guys story yesterday and what I was
just doing this for fun I was kind of
taking your story and then I was
replacing Franz with like other people
that we know and and just trying to
imagine like their success in your place
and in many cases it didn't work you
know like for instance you take George
Clooney you plug that into place and
like yes you can see that working with
George Clooney but then if you take some
more like Jonah Hill you put them in
this place of the honeymoon my brother
it's like you know what I don't I don't
know if that's a white Catholic that
that story is not going to work have you
thought about that at all in terms of
that the honeymoon with my brother kind
of gives you both sort of the perfect
story it's a story that fits both you
guys and then in terms of all of us what
can we do to hone in on what our story
is that maybe would attract an appeal to
other people why tickets you
it's it is universal everybody dreams of
escape I mean not everybody dreams about
taking a two-year honeymoon with the
brother although if anybody is dreaming
that you know my brother is here and is
available from a acts like he's got all
his shots and a good passport and um but
ya know we we all have that escape dream
you know in it it really comes in when
you've had a crummy day or you you know
you and your loved one or in a tough
situation or you know things are bad at
work you know we all dream about being
on that beach or you know and and so I
think some of the stories like this like
you know under the Tuscan Sun or
honeymoon or eat pray love they do tap
into something that we all think about
it's just not all of us act on it and
yet you know i'm a big proponent of
breaking away even if it's for a weekend
or you know taking out you know a couple
weeks off from work or doing just
changing up your routine i think i think
you know that that goes a long way
towards you know convincing yourself
that that you know hey i'm not stuck in
a rut you know my life isn't set i still
have control over this thing and i think
travel is a really really good way to do
that we you know we were talking earlier
about you know one of the huge regions
you know why you people should travel is
just the time to think you know you
realize how much your life is dominated
by bills and emails and you know cell
phone calls and and silly stuff stuff
that doesn't matter at all and and it's
not until you know break away from that
and you get out into some remote places
and you unplug and you detach that your
brain starts to kick in and ask yourself
some you know pretty basic questions
about life you know like what do I want
to do with it you know what makes me
happy what you know what what doesn't
make me have
what am I looking for in a partner what
do i what are my goals you know I it was
shocking to me that it it wasn't until
we got to the far ends of the world that
I even started asking myself these
questions and I'm holy smokes I you know
I've been out of college you know for
ten years and I've never asked you know
what I wanted to do when I grew up I
just kind of went from one job to
another but it's not like I was so in
love with those jobs how have your
personal relationships been affected you
know because we've observed with higher
profile people that the people around
them can sometimes have a hard time with
that success you know however they
perceive it in essence you know they
sort of feel like you know what you
you've taken my shot you know I don't
know what it is about human nature but
that you know but have you guys
experienced this in terms of before
honeymoon with my brother the
relationships that you had and then
afterward you know maybe the way that
you know people close to you perceived
you and what was happening with you guys
not not really the I would say though
not not the the book doing well but
there was definitely some you know
friends that I had before you know
taking the honeymoon that I'm not as
close with today and and conversely
others that I'm much closer to I your
priorities change and so I think you're
you're you shift towards friends with
similar priorities and I remember I used
to work at a PR firm and there was a guy
there named Mike Deaver Mike Deaver used
to be the chief of staff to Ronald
Reagan and at one time held one of the
most powerful jobs on the planet
literally and then he left and he got in
all kinds of legal trouble for lobbying
the White House he was an alcoholic he
almost lost his family his health was
failing he was being sued he's you know
being he was tried on a bunch of charges
and so he literally went from like the
highest point to the absolute lowest
point and I remember talking to him you
know years later when we were both
working for the same firm and this is a
guy I always respected and idolized
and I remember him telling me about the
importance of getting kicked on your ass
the importance of falling down and he
said you know one of the key things in
that is that you learn who's with you
and who's not with you and he said it
was so interesting to him when he went
through all his legal troubles that the
first people that called were not who we
thought would call you know one of the
first cause he got was from Tip O'Neill
who was speaker the house and a guy that
he had you know fought against for all
of these years he's like tipa he's like
I woke up every day trying to make
tipple meals life hell and Tip O'Neill
called and said whatever you need I'll
do it for you and conversely there was
some people on his staff that never
talked to him and and fled and didn't
want anything to do with them and he's
like that's great you know that's great
because I know where I know where I
stand you know and I know I know who's
with me and who's not and I you know we
didn't go through it to that level but
you know I do think I used to have this
really high-powered job where I gave out
millions of dollars to politicians and
they would come to the office and it was
great for my ego you know cuz they would
come and you know tell me you know how
wonderful i was and you know could they
please have a check and I'd say sure and
i'd write him a check and you know
obviously they don't call me anymore you
know i haven't some nut is closed with
with that set and thank God anything to
add no I think that you know another fun
thing about our success with the story
and everything is is how it's affected
our parents they really you know at
first they were very apprehensive about
these two bruh are we losing these guys
we have to go out and bring them back
put them in some real jobs again but
through the success of the book and the
stories and all the the joy it's brought
them
you know they really have they really
get a kick out of it especially in the
small town of Davis California they you
know these are my brothers are my sons
and they're very proud of us it's great
very cool is great we are currently in
the studio with Franz wisner and Kurt
wisner some more of their work as
available by visiting honeymoon with my
brother calm and how the world makes
love calm about your travels you have
said that the focus was on getting
enriched rather than getting rich you
know you two have traveled for two years
initially and I honey moved my brother
then we found out that you guys travel
for an additional three years after that
let me let me see so when you did return
home how much of the world had really
changed a lot we we started the the trip
the honeymoon and it's funny to say that
but we started the honeymoon you know
pretty 911 and then you know 911 took
place in and yeah there was this moment
where we thought you know do we go on
you know did we stop the honeymoon here
and did some soul-searching and
eventually decided to keep going and
that you know if there was any time that
the world needed greater dialogue needed
greater connectivity it was then and so
wanted to keep going and learning and
embracing and and did that and it wasn't
until the very end of the honeymoon that
I even thought about doing a book and it
was about the time when you know our
money was running out and we needed to
get back and I got it actually got an
offer to go back to my old firm and then
like hey you know even we dusted off a
real couch you know you can come on back
it's an ikea kappa am I just you know
the money was good and and the comfort
it would have been an easy job in
situation to go back to but it didn't
feel right and I knew I wanted to keep
traveling and I knew it
wanted to do something with Kurt and I
and you know I had tasted this freedom
and I didn't want to give it back and so
throughout the honeymoon I'd written a
lot of essays that kind of found their
way into newspapers and magazines and I
I told people you know don't I don't
want to be paid for this because I don't
want it to feel like a job I don't you
know just clean up my spelling you know
take out the swear words and you're free
to use whatever you want and so these
were all about frogs I mean when you say
they just happen to find their way he'll
help me here how do they just find their
way I had I I started doing these things
for friends and a lot of my friends were
in media and I had a lot of friends who
were reporters and they would email me
and say hey I read that you know essay
you wrote about the world's worst cab
driver you know or you know you the cult
of the backpackers or things you I'd
always write about people mmm because
that's what's interesting about the
planet and so they would send it on to
like the the travel editor at the San
Francisco Chronicle one so I get an
email from him saying hey you know your
friend Deborah sent me this article I'd
like to run it nice so that was great
but I it was the first time in my career
that I wrote from me I i I've been a
writer for a long time but you know
speechwriter press secretary that sort
of writing which in is easy but it's
it's not as as rewarding and so it
wasn't until the very end that we
decided to try to sell this as a book so
I took all those essays including one
that I wrote called honeymoon as my
brother because a lot of people would
come up to us on the road and say hey
you know you guys on vacation and we'd
say now rocks on my honeymoon and then
they look at kerneli what happened and
so we in this essay explained that you
know mano a mano hun
and I haven't had one complaint about my
spooning techniques and I haven't set
foot into one exclusive shopping
boutique it's because a funny thing
happened to me on the way to the altar
and did ab did a book proposal and sent
it out to all the the big publishers in
New York and promptly got rejected by
every single one of them you know with
some really you know goofy
responses saying things like you know
interesting story not the guy to ride it
and I'm thinking you know who who else
if you want Kurt to write he can ride it
yeah but that other than the two of us
you know who else was on the honeymoon
you got one that said the niches to
crowd yeah niche is too crowded I that
was crazy to me because I I to this day
I they don't know what niche it goes in
I mean we're in barnes and noble were in
memoir and a lot of bookstores weren't
travel in some book stores were just a
non-fiction in borders rest in peace
we're in self-help yeah next to doc
knows deck next to dr. Phil and dr. Ruth
nice well I it was the woman who
eventually signed you it was the same
art did you know her son didn't
something similar just happened to him
you're you're a hundred percent right
look she had just had I said she had a
17 year old son who'd just been dumped
and this was the first love in this
kid's life and she said all of these
emotions came pouring out of him that
she didn't even know existed and she
said it was like having a person inside
come out and she said I was I was
fascinated and and I wanted to give him
a hug and I and I wanted to learn more
and I she said in your proposal hit my
desk that day mm-hmm and at which point
kurt said god bless your son and i was
like no no no god bless the woman who
dumped your son right because she she
bought it and they'd spend very little
money on it but it didn't matter it was
a good excuse to to keep traveling into
and to keep writing so I spent a year
writing the book and you know I started
out I thought it was going to be more of
a travel log but it you know as in the
writing process when you're you're open
to it is you guys know these things have
a life of their own and and certain
storylines and characters pull you and
rise up in importance and others you
know repel you and they tend to fade
away and so yeah during that process it
evolved a lot from a travelogue more
into a brother bonding story a story
about you know our relationship with
LaRue our grandmother are our story
about the relationship with the world
those were the the bigger themes that it
started emerging I want to talk about
the movie deal and we're all running out
of time but I just have to ask you just
from going on the site and seeing these
wonderful book clubs of these very
supportive fans they're all women and I
can see why you both are very handsome
and charming and I can see why they'd be
intrigued but what do men say about this
because I'm sure not a lot of men are
willing to open up about something as
personal as this and we've we've seen
that they're taught not to so what do
men say about this what you do you
mentioned the the pictures of the book
clubs and yes the book clubs out there
are are they're the ones who have driven
the book and made it so successful but I
think you know a lot of women reading
the book in in bed and chuckling and
laughing or crying and their husband
saying what are you reading and they'd
be like I think you'll enjoy this book
too and so you know it men men
definitely enjoyed as well and I think
that they gravitate towards some of the
things we talked about earlier in the
escape Oh kind that kind of stuff right
because so much pressure is put on men
to be a breadwinner and gratis and
things and and the women really enjoy
bronzes his writing but also hearing the
man's feelings and and and you know and
as much as he put into that
very cool ok so the film the movie a
movie yeah well so the minutes a layup
right what do you want it's an original
story you know the the book the book
came out and it started to do fantastic
actually I should step back and say we
sold it actually before the book came
out we sold it our agent put it out on a
Friday and we sold it after crazy
bidding war on Monday to Sony Pictures
in mosaic media and they bought it as a
big broad-based comedy for Jim Carrey
wolf Ferrell and they bought it
basically as dumb and dumber and they
bought it without reading the book and
they just thought of wooded what a great
setup for a movie this could be you know
these two goofy brothers going around
the world and and you know we thought
all right you know that that's fine as
long as I love Dumb and Dumber I think
it's a great movie I love planes trains
and automobiles um you know we just
wanted a gazillion people to go see the
movie and a gazillion people to come out
of the movie and say you know hey that
was great and you know we should read
the book the books because the book was
what we controlled and we knew you know
the process that you know it's it's once
you sell it it's in their hands but but
we thought that they would make a good
movie well and in fact when we sold it
they said I'm shocked that nobody's
invented this story you know and in fact
since our books been out of it there
have been like similar scenes in movies
where people have been dumped at the
altar and so we you know we take pride
in that may how so we we then went out
and sold the book and went on the road
and met with any book club that would
meet us we'd go and we'd go to their
hometown and we loaded up Kurt's VW van
and we did a four-month to around the
country just with invites in 30
different states and beautiful great in
the real grassroots
campaign that propelled this book on to
the New York Times bestseller list and
so we meanwhile i think the sony and
mosaic were really struggling with what
kind of a movie to make that they bought
it as a broad-based comedy a gag driven
movie and when then they started reading
the book and they started reading about
people like LaRue and and our characters
and as the the producer told me at the
time he's like hey you know I I bought
it on title alone but he's like there's
a lot of there there and now I'm kind of
confused and I don't think they ever
solved that confusion and you it split
people into two camps there was one camp
that said broad-based comedy Dumb and
Dumber Planes Trains there was another
camp that said no no no no heartfelt you
know character-driven movie hello
they'll be funny moments obviously but
something a little little deeper and I
think the advice that they gave the
writer was you know split the difference
and he tried to split the difference and
as you guys know it never worked to
split the difference and so in the end
nobody was happy with the scripts and
Kurt and I at that point said you know
you guys thank you we appreciate all the
hard work we'd like to get the rights
back and so that took us another year of
negotiating and waiting and finally got
the rights back to the movie and when
was this this was last year oh yeah yeah
okay and so now we've taken a much
different approach on it it's kind of
like you know you gave your baby to a
school and they didn't take great care
of your baby so now you're a little more
protective of your baby and now we're
much you know more interested in doing
something that that we're a little more
involved in and that it feels right you
know that when we tell people on the
road hey you know this they bought this
movie for Jim Carrey and Will Ferrell
there was unanimous groan
from the book clubs you know our car
core our support out there they didn't
they didn't love that at all they they
wanted you know a much much more
thoughtful movie and and you know so did
we so we've we've just started working
with the writer actually the the writer
her name's kami delevingne and kami
actually lives in my building in
Brooklyn I live in Brooklyn now and she
wrote Blue Valentine which was a great
movie and you know really struction
amazing chords and so we're just now
starting this this process and new and
and you know just working on a treatment
that she just completed and and we're
just now starting to talk to people you
know who who want to get involved in
what really what we're looking for
people who love it as much as we do and
and who you know are dedicated to it and
and want to give it that TLC you know
here's what we're not interested is
anybody who said oh you know that movie
sold the Sony and so it's not hot
anymore good Hollywood is so fascinated
with hot you know and I'm like but what
about good you know we're so if anybody
you know brings that up that's just like
a non-starter to us we're like you know
thank you very much we're just going to
keep going on our own way do you think
the message is too deep and it might
scare what I call the middle class
masses no because I think that those
messages can really be simplified you
know like everybody dreams of the skate
like we were talking about everybody
dreams about an improved relationship
with a family member you know these
these these themes take place in our
lives all day every day it's just ours
was happened to be played out around the
world I don't and I don't think you know
the book isn't a travelogue and you know
I don't think the movie should be either
that it's just it's a very interesting
you know backdrop to a more you know
universal theme
thank you thank you we've been speaking
with France and Kurt wisner for more on
the brothers please visit honeymoon with
my brother calm and Francis latest
project how the world makes love calm
and we'd like to thank our guy Rowan and
rosner he's a gentleman you seldom see
or hear but he plays a huge part in what
we do yeah our gratitude this has been
really special heaven you having the
rest is and thanks very much to your
audience and yeah give us a shout and we
just were we're looking forward to
seeing the film because we've been
waiting for it and we wondered yeah who
knows maybe what s is responsible for
putting the team together why on earth
would you sometime you just you just put
the bar you put the thought out here
there and put it off their intention our
vintage yes indeed that's until reason
would you like to hear your project or
business mentioned during one of our
shows or displayed on our site to
advertise with film courage calm and our
radio program please inquire through
film courage calm via our contact page
will be here next Sunday Nellie talk
radio comm with actor kevin chapman
kevin has been in numerous roles
including as detective Lionel Fusco on
the show person of interest Terrence on
rescue me Freddie cork on brotherhood
one of my favorites sunshine cleaning as
Carl ladder ladder 49 boondock saints it
I mean it goes on and on for more
information like a pin please visit
kevin chapman com or is IMDB page to see
all those credits and that does it for
us folks until next Sunday have a great
week
you